[Music]  playback  this is the entertainment capital of the  world  i'll give you three weeks to get this  show up and running  johnny you're gonna be working with the  number one choreographer in red shore  city yuck that is rubbish so bad wow  he's freaking me out  i don't see your temper  i'm really having second thoughts about  this  i can't do this can i try this girl  [Music]  you're terrific but can she act  take that you nasty alien monster  did i do good oh boy  you have no idea what you're getting  into  whatever podunk town they crawled out of  that's where they belong  we cannot let that bully steal our hopes  and dreams guts  faith these are the things you need now  good evening it is my pleasure to  present to you a brand new show  featuring the return of clay halloway  [Music]  [Music]  the journey of a lifetime is about to  begin  [Music]  i don't suppose any of you can tap dance  huh  [Music]  you